-How are you doing?
How's the family doing?
How are the kids?
-They're getting bigger.
-They are.
-That's what happens.
Yeah, it turns out they grow.
-How old's the baby now.
-He's two and a half.
-Oh, he's so cute.
-Yeah, he's so cute.
He's so cute.
Yeah, everybody's good.
-Does he know about
Christmas really yet or not?
-Um, I've been trying to,
like, kind of, like,
lead him towards that.
We've been watching the Rudolph
claymation thing a lot.
-Yeah, that's good.
-And yeah, he likes it.
He's like "Oh, Rudolph."
-Yeah.
He's already into that.
-He loves him.
-Does your daughter have
a list of toys and things?
-She does have a list
of toys and things,
but they're pretty specific.
So she'll be --
she'll be like, I want --
Okay, I want a dress.
It's fluffy on the top,
and then on the sides,
it's got like, little sequins.
I'm like, what is this thing?
-It's very specific.
-Yeah, yeah,
it's like too specific.
-Were you like that as a kid?
-Um, no.
I mean, I, like, my best
if I think about, like,
my favorite thing I ever got,
I got a "Jurassic Park"
pup tent that I slept in
for like six months
in my bedroom on the floor.
-So a tent on the floor?
-Yeah.
My sister was not as happy about
it because we shared a room,
but yes, I pitched a tent
in our -- in our bedroom
and slept on the hard floor,
comfortably
slept on the hard floor because
we had like no bones back then
or I don't know what.
-We did that all the time, too.
We would ask to sleep
on the floor.
-Why didn't it hurt then?
-It was a treat.
-I don't understand.
-We had a sleeping bag.
We'd be like, mom,
can we -- could me
and Gloria just like
camp out in the living room?
-I feel like if I slept
on the floor now,
I would, like, disintegrate.
-I know.
-I would just turn into --
I'd be like, boneless
when I woke up, yeah.
-That's true really funny,
-Yeah.
-I wanted to ask you something.
This is a clip that's viral.
A clip of you being interviewed
on the red carpet.
This is in 2006...
-Oh, God.
-...and I don't,
if you remember this story,
but a woman walked --
-Is it offensive? What did I do?
-No, no no, no.
It's cool. No, no, it's cool.
A woman walks behind you, and it
looks like she fully disappears.
Do you know
what I'm talking about?
-No.
-Watch this video.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
-And what was the highlight
of the evening for you tonight?
-Philip Seymour Hoffman
winning for best actor
for a drama.
Oh, my God,
that -- that is my mom.
That is my mom.
-Wait. What?
-That's my mom.
-Wait, let's watch it again.
That's your mom? But what...?
-That woman with the dark hair?
-Yes.
-Is my mother.
-That's your mom?
-That's my mom, yes.
-Philip Seymour Hoffman winning
for best actor for a drama.
-And where...?
-I've been looking for her for,
like, the last 15 years.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You are the best.
That is so funny.
-That is very strange.
-That's your mom?
-That is fully my mom.
-Hi, mom. That's so cute.
-That is weird.
Where did she go?
-[ Laughs ]